That's- that's not a good sound!
Ooooooohhhhaa
AAAAAAAGH!!!
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to the Joy of Creation: Story Mode.
Now we're on the way to the living room and we got a long way to go before we get to the end of this game...
.. And I have a funky feeling that's going to end in either the attic or the basement.
But with that being said we got to get through the living room first. Let's go into..
oooh...
Let's go into the living room and see what happens in there
Scott:  Do you really think it was a good idea letting him stay?
Val: Well, it's not like he was in any condition to do anything. Did you see his clothes?
Val: It's like he... came out of a bonfire...
Scott: I-I mean, I could've...
Mark: A bonfire?
Scott: ...you know, called an ambulance, maybe dropped him off near a hospital would've been better.
Scott: I-ah-I just don't think I feel comfortable with a complete stranger just... ending up sleeping in our house is all.
Val: Oh, honey...
Val: You're worried about the kids.
Scott: Of course I'm worried about the kids. He's sleeping right next to them. How can I not be? What if he's faking,  Val?
Val: We cOuLd stay here to make sure nothing happens, if you're that worried.
Scott: All night?
Val:  Of course all night! Come on, don't you wanna spend time with me more?
You ARE done updating your site for the anniversary.
How about we just sit here in the living room and watch some TV while we keep an eye on the kids?
Scott: I-I mean, uh...
Sure, I guess.. yeah, I guess we could do that I-
I just got to go make sure one more time nothing's wrong, all right? I'll be right back.
Val: Okay, I'll just stay right here, but don't take too long!
You worry too much.
MARK: I know what's going on here this game-
...Eaeeee...
Val: Wh-what was that!?
This game is LITERALLY about Scott Cawthon, the developer of Five Nights at Freddy's.
Interestingly interesting huh, I don't know. Uh. I donanow uh free-roaming in-incoming apparently..
Ooohhhh...
Michael: Uhm- hello, is someone there?
Mark: YES!
If anyone can hear me please respond immediately.
Val: Who is it? What in God's name is going on here?
Michael: Oh um, uhm.. It's me, Michael.
Uh. Look- there's no time to explain just know that you are in grave danger. Is Scott there with you?
Val: My husband? (Mark: Scott)
No he isn't h-he just went to...
What do you mean I'm in danger?!
Michael: (Mumbling: Oh no) Uh, Ma'am, I am very, VERY sorry. This is all my fault- you need to stay calm.
I'll try to help you through this, just please listen to me very carefully.
Val: W-W-What..?
Michael: Listen, there are monsters that are going to arrive to your room real soon. If they see you, you are DEAD.
Do you understand that ma'am? It is VERY important that whatever occurs, just
DONT let them see you!
Alright?
MICHAEL: I know, I know, look... Just...
... you're in the living room, right? Try to focus on the three entrances
behind you. The exit to the house should be locked and they won't come though there.
If there are any monitors nearby, then they should be forced to produce a camera system for you.
Ma'am, is the TV in your living room turned on?
Val: Uh... Yes, but it's filled with static.
Michael: Alright now, please keep an eye on it, it should help you.
Look, they usually come from either the left side, or the right side -- you have nothing to stop them.
So, if you see one of them about that to the room just.. HiDe
Val: Hide?! Hide where?
Michael: Uh- Just-.. l-look just stay out of sight okay??
Yes, if they try to come in just move somewhere they won't be able to see you, okay?
Well, I don't know which one will come from which side..
..but if you look at the TV, you might be able to tell by yourself.
Maybe if you can, try to see if you can look through the doors too.
Uh, the windows...
Keyholes.. yes, keyholes! If any of your doors has a keyhole you can peek through keep checking it.
They won't notice you on the other side, trust me.
Uh..
So yes, I can't stress this enough. If anything comes through those doors,
Hide.
Just hide away from view.
You might hear noises later on in the night- pay attention to those. Don't look at anything that appears in your room and..
..Try to stay safe, please.
Val: D-Do I have to stay here all night!?
What about my children? What about my husband?
Michael: Look, it's very hard to explain ma'am..
..And no, just wait until 6:00 a.m to be safe, but don't worry- time will pass much faster.
(Knocking in background)
Just keep an eye on the clock and wait for that time. They should all be gone in a few minutes, and then the hours will reset.
Now please if you survive, I need you to grab your kids and get out of this house as soon as possible.
I'm going to help Scott get out of here myself. Don't worry.
Just please get yourself and your sons out of harm's way.
Val: I-I don't understand.. What is even happening?
How do you know how is this stuff? Wh-
..Wait.
Wait a second.. How do you know my husband's name?
I was there when he found you Michael. He never said his name. How do you know?
Michael?
Mark: Okay, great. Yeah. This is weird. All right. I don't know what it means by HIDE; THERE'S NOWHERE TO HIDE HERE!
IT'S A BIG EMPTY ROOM WHERE AM I GONNA GO AM I GONNA SLIDE INTO THE BOOKSHELF???
AM I GONNA SLIP UNDER THE COUCH???
File myself away... under "FUBBERNUCKED???"
That's what I am!
Might as well be my name. Okay. These don't have keyholes, so I can't exactly look through it.. Oh boy.
I don't know where it wants me to hide what in the world doesn't mean by...
... that looks bad
Oh, these look bad! Oh boy (x6)
Oh b- Oh boy.
oh bo - oh boned! Oh boned, I am. Oh say, can you see how boned I am in my butt.
Oh, boy. Oh b- Oh, bo- Oh boy.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do about this.
I've only got Foxy and Freddy on the command screen here...
...and I don't know what I'm supposed to do when they get here.
Oh. Is it just the two of them?
Oh! They're coming up to a door oh, God!
UH!
Excuse you!! Why does it seem like the same goddamn door?!
UH
(in French) Pardon me!
I don't know what to-
AHH!
WAAAAAH EYYY OH HI
Oh, its both!
Ow!!
What the fuck?!
HOW'RE YOU S'POSED TO - HIDE??
Hide in places..?! (Mark goes hysterical, sobs: "..and they won't see you.")
(Mark laughs, unconvinced by strategy tip)
You said that the front door was going to be locked!
.. Oh, the front door was probably the one with the poster on it. Oh, I'm dumb, okay, alright.
That's the one! This one's gonna be a bioitch!
This is gonna be a biooioiiooiitch. Okay, so this is the front door? I still can't honka that.
Alright, so let me think about this logically. Oh, no still paused huh?
(Mark makes a brbrb noise.) Okay think about this Markimoo, where logically in this place, could you hide can I turn out the lighty-loos?
No, I can't! I can't go through there. I can't look in there. I can't hide in any one of these shoeboxes.
Can't hide in the filing cabinet! Yeah, I'm bonerowned, is what I am. I'm just purely boned. I'm so strongly boned!
I'm gonna try to hide on this side of the room. Maybe foxy can only see movement.
(Door slams open.)
Uh oh. Well that's-
(Foxy Jump scare!)
There were two of you. Alrighty then! Well, that was fun. I'm gonna be right here
I'm g- I'm gonna get a face full of Foxy. That's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna get a face full of Foxy!
Hey, buddy
Hey, I'm where the game hint-
ohh.. my god!
did-
Is that doing something?
Is that actually.. wait wait wait wait wait- is that actually doing something?
How does that work?! How do- how does it work? Am I tapping into their cerebral cortex?
Did- does that actually work? Is that how that is?!
Oh, that's how it actually is, isn't it..
Oh, my God it is! Holy shit, okay?
Oh, that's super weird, but I think I'm okay. I think I.. ohh-
Alrighty then alright, so if I'm pausing one-
Somehow, the other one is slightly ahead. That's how you get them out of rhythm. Then if Foxy's coming through one door..
I can hide from- woah. oh?
Okay, alright weird stopping, but alright
Alright, then if Foxy's coming through this door, then I can hide here??
.. from Foxy, and then go over there??
Okay???
Ooh boy. That's weird!
♪Then go over to the other side.♪
Oh!!
Hi!! Freddy boi!!
Freddy Boy!!!
Freddy boy. How you doing, Freddy boy?
Alrighty then! Uh oh.. is that?
Okay, I thought I heard something over there, but hey we did something! Okay...
We survived one hour! Who do we got and where... okay?
They're going to continually be off rhythm now? Because it looks like they're going to continually be off rhythm now.
So, if they're in that rhythm, maybe they come in at random.. But I still don't know what's going on over here!
Well, seems like something bad might happen over there, but so far so good..  Okay.
That must be.. the baby?
I heard a noise!
Whoa! I hear a noise!! Ooh boy, okay!! Something back there?
Hi! Hello! Who are you?
Bonnie?!
Is that you Bonnie?!
How do I hide from
BONNIE?! I don't know how I hide from Bonnie..
Okay, we got incoming though. We got incoming but there's no hiding from that.. Oh boy
Bonnie might be coming down, and Bonnie might bash open those doors and bash in my skull with his big body
Hi..
Oh that's bad!
Ow..
should have, um..
should have paid more attention to the cameras.
(Knocking sound from the front door)
Hello, what was that?
I don't like the sound of those noises!! Where's Freddy?
Where's Fredboy- oh, there he is. Hi Fredboy. How you doing? Welcome to my abode.
I've got a grave concern with Bonnie.
That's bad, what was that?
Look, I'm a risk a look oh
That's a bad look! Right, okay! Maybe over here is gonna be okay?
♪I don't know, I don't know I'm probably boned.♪
(Again, the knocking from the front door.)
Excuse you?!
What the hell is that?! Whoa!! Hi Bonnie. Hi- hi, how ya doing buddy? How ya doing buddy Bonnie? Okay then alright then.
Who's where? Who's where? Who is --
where is -- Who's doing what?
Foxy- okay Foxy's coming up on it. I'm gonna pause Freddy!
I don't know what the banging in the vents is. Probably Chica but uh, you know I don't have time to worry about that!
As long as I can- okay! Go, go, go, go! Go, go!
♪ Go, go, go, go, go! ♪
♪ Please don't eat my brains! ♪
♪ Hi.. ♪
Okay..
♪Dee Dee Dee, Yee Dee Dee, Deedly Dee Dee Deedly Dee♪ (tune of Spiderman)
If Chica comes anywhere, I'ma be so...
Okay?
I think I can do this! It seems, oddly manageable..
Okay, it's weird. It is weird. Don't get me wrong. It's really weird, but it works! Surprisingly..
Turn that.. whoa- what was that?
Is that uh.. Is that Mr. uh...
Bonnster? Okay, Bonnster's a ways away.
Means I got time either this next cycle.
Maybe that's- That's- that's not a good soOUUND!!(Quick, stand up Mark!)
Aaaaaa-AAAAAAAGH!!!
Okay, am I dead?! ♪ I'm not dead. ♪ I'm not dead. ♪ I'm not dead. ♪ I'm not dead!! ♪
♪ That's right. You just scare me!! But that's okay! ♪
♪ Don't listen to the noises of the night~ ♪
Go, go, go! I don't know where Freddy is!
Chica is a BIIIIG bitch!
Hi Freddy. Welcome to the party. Oh boy. I guess I'm okay!
(Distressed Markimoo sounds.)
I don't like that! Okay, where's BonBon? Woo! Okay BonBon's right there, okay, BonBon's right there, okay BonBon come on in!
Come on in BonBon! Here comes Bonnie.
Any minute now? Hi. Welcome.
Okay, all right okay, okay, okay. Check out Foxy, Foxy, Foxy. Where's Foxy? Coming down the way, okay.
Okay, Foxy's right at the door.. which is fine.
I don't like that..
Okay, here we go! (Another distressed noise)
Go, go, go!
Good thing Chica wasn't there! Hahaha.
Shitty Pibiti.
shitty pudidly.
Okay, we're doing pretty good. Oh, hey. How's it going?
I was you saying how good we were doing you want to change that fact? Huh Big Boi?
Oh, you want to come out of here and fuck up my day?
That's right. You better get out of here.
What are we going on here?
Okay, no BonBon yet. Which is good, which is fine totally fine. Where's Foxy? Foxy coming around the corner?
Chica.. hopefully not here. There's Freddy.
They're a good bit separated. Which is nice, but it seems like someone might be accelerating if I'm not mistaken..
That's.. that's bad! That's bad, okay, okay, ah..
Fuck you. Give a little more pause will more pause okay?
Go!! Now!!!!
Hi, oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
Go, go, go, go! Gahh.. that was close. That was too close, Freddy!
Fredboy, that was waaay too close!
I'm going to just, you know. Going to anticipate this.
No? Okay. I'm gonna look-
Ooh! That's- that's bad! But not that bad.
Not bad as bad as it could be!
Oh, god. They're right on top of each other..
AHHH
I"M FUCKED
I'M FUCKED I'M FUCKED I'M FUCKED- AHHHHH
Fuckleduckle. Oh my god. Oh my God that was -- I almost ran right into that door then Foxy might have known something
What do we got here? Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa waaaayyy
Okay!!
Alrighty then!!
Okay, I think I'm almost through this just got to control them a little bit longer.
So freeze Foxy- actually Foxy's fine. Foxy can come on down. That means they're opposite again..
Freddy, you stay frozen.
Hey, don't look that way, that'd be bad. Whoa. What the fuck was that? What am I doing wait? Whoa? Whoa, whoa, whoa that- hey!
(Ominous music) The fuck is that?!
What the fuck happened? What the fuck is happening?
'Scuse you!!
Oh my god, I don't know what's happening, but I don't like it. It's 5:00 a.m.,
and I'm too close to this to be bullshitted! Oh, I have eyes on the walls.
Ho boy..
He's almost at the door. Freeze Foxy just a little bit longer...
Here we go. UUUWAAAAAUUU!
Oh boy...
I think that was... okay. I think that actually might have been.. oh don't get fucked by that!
Oh god
Oh, God, I'm fucked!
I think it'll be Foxy first, but I'm not sure. Heyyy, it was Foxy first, okay.
I'm just gonna tuck in that corner. Go away. Go away, go away ! Now now now now go go
Fuck go! Okay, I think...
Then it's gonna be
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Oh shit!!
Oh fuck! Fuck, fuck, fuck!
Where's Freddy, where's Freddy? Where's Freddy? Oookay, Freddy's right there? Go Freddy. Go Freddy. Go Freddy go. Go?
Then, as soon as Freddy goes, I'm diving in that corner in dat-di...
Go Freddy, go go go go Freddy. Go Freddy. Go Freddy. Go Freddy. Go Go, Freddy GO!
Yes!!!
(Markimoo makes a strange sound.)
Incre- The Haunted Woods: Increased paranormal sightings near the countryside sparks interest for a full investigation.
That was nerve-wracking, that was neeeerve-wracking, that was nerve-wracking.
That was so nerve-wracking! That was nerve-wracking.
I'm like gahhh- so twitchy right now! Oh!
Okay, but I did it. I did it. I did it, okay.
It's really hard,
but the mechanics are good! Like, it's interesting. Like these mechanics are interesting because I've never seen them before
in a Five Nights at Freddy's game, anyway.. Or an Indie game, I guess. Man! Good shit, though. Good shit. Good shit.
Good shit. So anyway, that is all for The Living Room. That was a challenge, but I got through it
okay. Next up is... Oh, The Office. Oh great...(oh boy, that's gonna be fun..)
So anyway, that is
The Living Room; The Office is up next. So thank you, everybody, so much for watching and
let me know what you though of this down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you... in the next video.
Buh-bye!